[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today we're going to be talking about
the science of meditation let me first
introduce my co-host marcia belski not
your first time with us welcome back
marcia thank you so much so excited to
be back and i feel like our topic will
be
a little easier for me to understand
than cryptocurrency oh that's true
that wasn't that fast topic
we wanted you to stay with every every
bit of that the quantum
computations yes
start with phd
exactly
so you're a comedian and a musician
that's a potent combo so
i i love your work and uh you know let's
presume this is not the last time you'll
be on star talk so listen let's
introduce our our guest for the day and
that's going to be dan harris
many of you might recognize that name
and his face uh he was he's been
correspondent for abc news like forever
and then he retired
retired and then took up meditation i
think he'd been doing it for a while but
then made it full time dan welcome to
star talk thank you you're making me
feel old i was a correspondent forever
it reminds me i gave a speech i gave a
speech once at syracuse university and a
lot of the kids were coming up to me and
saying i've been watching you my whole
life so i was like next
next
since i was a child in the second world
war
so dan just just
a little bit about your career
you weren't just sitting at the desk i
mean you you know you have emmy awards
for your reporting you um
so what do you think of the the netflix
documentary don't look up what do you
think of that
for a minute for a minute i didn't hear
documentary
[Laughter]
because the media is is deeply
implicated in that yes
i have no especially now that i'm not uh
part of the media i'll yeah i'll start
bashing and i won't get sensitive yeah
because you were at the good morning
america desk for a while and that's just
what kind of programming they were sort
of parodying there so yes yes okay
all right i'm going to bring that here
whatever you ask me i'm just going to
deny and make a choice that gets me out
of it
so so tell me you've got this app
and even before the app tell me about
this 10
happier concept that you've been engaged
in not only while you are correspondent
but even in retirement
yes i'll try to give you the super quick
version
it all started because i had a panic
attack on
national television back in 2004 you can
google that if you want to see it yeah
but it was live wow
yeah um it was like um
a better version of al capone's vault
you know when you uh when geraldo rivera
did that live show on prime time
television and didn't find anything in
al capone's vault this was live and
actually something happened i lost my
mind and um
there was an audience of 5.019 million
people on a warm june morning in 2004
and the reason i had a panic attack i
found out later is um
because i was doing some very dumb stuff
in my personal life i had spent
a lot of time in war zones that's not
the dumb stuff the the war zones was
part of my that was part of my reporting
job but i came home from that from those
experiences in iraq and afghanistan and
other places and i got depressed
and i very unwisely self-medicated with
recreational drugs even though i wasn't
high on on good morning america
my doctor later explained that it wasn't
my drug use was enough to change my
brain chemistry and make it more likely
for me to freak out and so that
experience kind of put me on this
journey that ultimately landed me on
meditation
so marcia as a comedian you you
experience exactly that same war zone
thing don't you
i definitely am relating to it though
because i think also yeah i started
having really bad panic attacks and
i don't like you know xanax and things
like that i'll only take it when i
really have to so i have tried
meditation so i'm super interested to
like hear your journey for sure right
and if a comedian has a panic attack
that's the that's that's that's the end
of the that's the end right
it is it's hard to because yeah like
i've only ever panicked on stage one
time and it was kind of weird where i
was just like silent for 20 seconds and
then managed to kind of get them back
but it's it's a freaky i can't imagine
doing it on live tv it's such a freaky
experience and if you haven't had a
panic attack i mean it literally feels
like you can't breathe it feels like
you're having a heart attack and you
can't tell anything to your brain that's
like i'm not dying your brain is just
like this is it this is it
so dan you're implying that had you not
had these
uh
coexisting factors you might not have
gone through that episode is that
correct
yes i mean i did have stage fright
you know which
i made a joke in one of my books that my
career
up until that date represented a triumph
of narcissism over fear um because i
would like to be on television but i had
stage fright and uh so i was always kind
of walking the line but then you add in
significant amounts of cocaine and uh i
crossed the line to freak out zone so
this doesn't help with anxiety
so you both have data on this yes so
this is all very important feeder
information because when we go to our
second and third segment we'll be
bringing on friend of star talk heather
berlin who's our sort of resident
neuroscientist and so all these factors
will matter when we share
what you're telling us with her so so
tell us now
who got you started on meditation who
thought who figured that would work for
you
well it was multifactorial but i think
the the most important variable was my
wife um uh she gave me a gift of a book
by a guy named dr mark epstein who is a
psychiatrist based in new york city
where we lived until recently and um
he
uh has written a beautiful series of
books about the overlap between
psychology and buddhism and i didn't
actually know much about buddhism other
than the fact that i had stolen a um
buddha statue from a local gardening
store when i was in high school because
i thought it would help me with the
latest oh high school okay my bedroom uh
yeah high school so didn't it because
if you have a buddha on your on your
windowsill you're you're hip you're cool
yeah like we got the freaking british
museum over here in the 80s in the 80s
um
anyway the statute of limitation on that
has passed so i think i can talk about
it anyway i didn't know anything about
buddhism but i read this book and and i
realized that that um there was so much
in here that spoke to where the the way
my mind works the buddha called it the
monkey mind this this constantly
active uh leaping from one hit of
pleasant experience one promotion one
slice of cake one latte to the next and
yet never fully satisfied it's the
monkey mind minus throwing the poop i'm
guessing
well i mean i don't know about your mind
for anxiety as well cocaine and coffee
grinder correct
i agree with you marcia i disagree with
you neil because i i don't know about
your mind but my mind's throwing a lot
of poop
at other people oh yeah and
at myself it's an
omnidirectional poop dispenser oh man
okay so it's a it's a figurative poop
dispenser there you go all right
so all right so and that sets you on
your course so i'm guessing here that
there's a very educated guess that the
uh the meditation
has
it's all about sort of introspection as
is so much of eastern philosophy so the
resonance there is is kind of
pre
uh preordained right
i mean it's it's not the interest the
word introspection is interesting
because it's not the introspection in
the way i think we in the west might
think of it because you're not sitting
there analyzing your thoughts the way
you would in therapy by the way i'm pro
therapy i go to therapists and et cetera
et cetera so that's not a degradation of
therapy but this is more of a mental
exercise
which i know you'll get at in your
second and third segments with um your
neurosciences
yeah i mean heather can talk about this
but i'll just preview it by saying that
and i can describe what meditation is if
you want but it is essentially like a
series of exercises for your brain and
by extension your mind and you can see
the changes on the brain scans and
that's really compelling so it's not
naval gazing in in the way in which we
in the west might consider it
got it so it's it's goes beyond woo-woo
right as they say where if you if you
have measurable data on changes in your
brain scans
it means you're actually doing something
and it's not just talk at that point
is that fair
yeah i think it is fair i mean
it's interesting the more i've gotten
into it the the more open
i am to
i i at first i was you know i was raised
by by academic physicians i'm married to
an academic physician i i was not smart
enough to to be a doctor so i wear
makeup and talk to television cameras
for a living but
the science is really what got me over
the hump and allowed to uh it allowed me
to do this thing but the more i get into
it the the more and this is probably an
inhospitable place to say this but the
more open i am to things that might ha i
might have dismissed as
now i would just consider sort of other
ways of knowing things and that we just
and that we're always looking for
scientific validation but maybe you know
i don't meditate now because i think
it's going to change my brain i meditate
because i know
it makes me less of an [ __ ] to myself
and others and that's really helpful
okay that anything that reduces the
assaholic in the world is a good thing
no matter what the foundations are so
what let's let's go back to square one
what is meditation just give me your
best sort of definition for it so that
we can start there
marsha i know you've done it what uh
what flavor of meditation did you do do
you remember
for me
it's it's really hard for me to meditate
and what i noticed is um
the more i would try and structure it
the less likely i was to actually just
sit there and be present like i would
try and get
um
tapes and things like that so the times
i found i best meditate or after i do
yoga whenever they have the like 10 down
lay down period those have been my most
successful times i think because my body
has exercised and i can
sort of meditate at that moment
and then just truly laying in bed in the
mornings and for me it's putting my
phone in a different room and forcing
myself not to like
go check it for an hour and then i can
actually just sit there
and think and not watch tv and that's
what i call meditating i don't know if
it actually is
but that's sort of what's helped me with
my anxiety especially over this last
year to try and stay present and i do
little things like i'll tap
tap my heart tap my head and
physical things like that and
point to the
like i don't know if you've done this
when you have panic attacks but you
point up and you say i see the ceiling i
see the door you just start naming
things around you to keep yourself
present so
he asked you what flavors that sounds
like vanilla
that's the most vanilla yeah i'm entry
level meditation okay so i'd be rocky
road maybe
i want to get to mint chocolate chip
level yeah there you go there you go
okay so so what so what flavor
uh dan are you
well yeah maybe i can help disambiguate
the the flavors here so there
the word meditation is a little bit like
the word sports i mean it describes a
whole range of activities marcia hit on
about 75 of them in her paragraph that
she just uttered there and yeah and and
that's all good for me i think that i
usually start with a very basic form of
meditation called mindfulness which is
derived from buddhism but has been
thoroughly secularized
and has now been studied in the labs
extensively
and the real they're really three
beginning steps for this one is
sit comfortably
you can lie down if you want i don't or
you can put yourself in the lotus
position i don't like to do that because
i'm 50 years old and not very limber but
you just kind of sit comfortably close
your eyes that's the first step the
second step is to bring your full
attention to the feeling of one thing
usually your breath
coming in and going out if you don't
like focusing on your breath some people
find that sort of an anxiogenic and
anxiety producing thing so you can just
feel the your full body sitting or lying
down just picking one thing to focus on
and then the third step is as soon as
you try to do this you just try to feel
your breath or feel your body sitting in
a chair your mind's gonna go bonkers
this is the monkey mind and you'll see
that you're starting to start planning a
homicide or you're wondering you know
when's lunch or whatever
and the whole game is just to notice
when you've become distracted and to
start again and again and again you're
not trying to clear your mind that's
impossible unless you're enlightened or
you've died the whole game is just to
notice when you've got become distracted
and start again and again and again and
the benefit
is mindfulness this kind of
self-awareness that allows you to see
the chaos and cacophony of your own mind
without being owned by it
wow so that's why the silence matters
because that could create an artificial
distraction that is needless in your
efforts to achieve your goals
you know for some people meditate with
um
music i've never understood exactly how
that works how about those tones you
know those bells that you hear sometimes
uh that might resonate with some
frequency within your self
so there's sound
baths which again that's not something i
really understand or have done much of
you the bells often in the in the flavor
of meditation i come from are used to
start or end a session of meditation oh
got you okay um so like i said it's very
pavlovian very very pavlovian by the way
yes
yes some of those sounds i like some of
the ohms and the like the bells kind of
clear out your head it feels like
mouthwash in your brain some of the
frequencies i like that analogy but just
to be clear for those who don't
otherwise know these aren't like
dinner bells or sleigh bells they're
they're tonal bells right they're like
i can only meditate to slay bells
no whale noises no no no i need more
cowbell that's what that's
santa screaming yeah
so you have so you have an app called
the 10 percent happier
app
well i mean the app is named for the the
what you do
and
you know i'm
i
i want to be twenty percent happier
why are you holding me back
to ten percent
you know
what's what's the thinking behind that
or did you borrow that from the business
world where they say i want you to give
110 today and that's of course
mathematically not real but
spiritually emotionally it might mean
something so where are you coming from
when you get this 10 thing going i got
interested in meditation in 2008 or nine
before it was cool it was like the first
time in my life i've ever been ahead of
a trend and um
some of my well there was the entire
1960s and 70s with you know the maharaji
you know i mean so there was some
meditation going on back then just but
you you were only just born see so
for you to say you're a 50 year old
american say i was ahead of the game i
started meditation
no what you might maybe uh yeah i'll let
me let me offer you a way out of what
you just said uh could it be that you
started meditating early in the social
media universe how about that
i appreciate you offering me the way out
i would say maybe i got interested in
meditation before the second wave of
cool happened because you're absolutely
right it was cool in the 60s and 70s
exactly exactly
the mahara
paul mccartney john lennon they were all
doing it so you're absolutely right it
was cool in the 60s and 70s then it went
away it got kind of mocked as part of
the um
uh
60s becoming a bit of a cultural
caricature
and then so i got interested in
2009 uh and um
a lot of my friends thought it was weird
and they were making fun of me and one
day a friend of mine at work was saying
what's
the matter with you like why are you
doing this thing and i kind of out of
nowhere said yeah because it makes me
like ten percent happier
and i could see the look on her face
change from scorn to mild interest oh
that's clever
okay all right you got me there all
right ten percent yeah i can let me go
with the ten percent and that's a
starter package right exactly and since
since now i'm stuck with math questions
and jokes for my whole life i'll just
double down on that to say
that it's like any good investment
the ten percent compounds annually the
radical good news of meditation
is that and this is what the science is
showing us is that happiness
is not a factory setting that is
unalterable it's a skill you can
practice
and this practice the benefits compound
over time and that is incredibly
compelling hence 10
and i wrote a book called 10 happier
which i thought was going to be mildly
embarrassing and go away and then it
kind of led to a podcast where i
interview meditation experts and then
this meditation app which well that's
that's a very natural arc of an active
person who's trying to get the job done
so congratulations on that when did the
book come out
almost eight years ago okay 2014. the 10
happier book and okay we can look for
that and maybe link to it so
so you have i noticed um i picked up a
couple of your um the episodes if i call
them that uh you have you have a cadre
of meditation experts that help the
listener to the podcast get into
different meditative states right and as
i understand correctly these different
meditation experts
are are slightly differently tuned
relative to what your needs might be if
you then tune in is that
if you listen is that correct yeah i
mean i think there are there are
different use cases for meditation we
have a a lot of meditations that help
you fall asleep uh some for first thing
in the morning uh there are meditations
that help you boost your self-awareness
this word mindfulness that gets tossed
around a lot another skill that
meditation has been shown through a lot
of research to help you with is
compassion or you might just say
friendliness warmth if you want to get
grandiose about it love even and so
that's a really compelling thing to
think about as a skill and as we look
out at the for me personally as i look
out at the world and how screwed up it
is
the notion that we can boost
our capacity and the capacity of other
human beings to
get out of their own heads and view the
world empathetically through the eyes of
others that that is a skill that's a
very hopeful thing so what's the
difference between knowing your own mind
better
and then being able to interact with
other people better so for example is
there a meditation
course let's call it that
for comedians where they can better get
in the head of their audience
because they want the audience to laugh
right and if they don't laugh they're
not connecting in the way they need so
could you in the limit of this from what
you're describing have a meditation app
for a meditation
course flavor for every need somebody
has in society so then you lift all
boats yes rather than just the boats of
the people who have emotional inner
needs to
um you know to soften
i i mean we do courses on stress anxiety
also
relationships
productivity
having more self-awareness in in your
daily life we we there there are there
is no aspect of your life that you can't
make more awesome
through
intentionally turning it into a practice
and that's what that's what the hardest
part is though
you start to realize like oh i could fix
all my own life it is all me and then
it's like ugh no
it's so much work
i don't think you should just to respond
to you marcia i don't think the goal is
to try to fix quote unquote everything
all at once i think the goal is marginal
improvement over time and that marcia he
said he's a ten percent guy so don't try
to ask him
i like instant gratification
i don't have time for this marginal
improvement over time
give me a quick bit give me the cocaine
you know
fix it now
fix it you already said you didn't like
xanax so i mean you've taken a big tool
off the table right so dan let me let me
give a personal story here it's not in
that story but just i i'm like the
opposite of anxious okay if i speak
in a public setting
it is i'm as calm as like i'm sitting in
my living room and 3 000 people are just
there and we're chilling in the living
room that's what it feels like to me so
i have no anxiety at all i'm very
comfortable in those settings and
i there are other things that i know
people reach for to compensate for what
they might need i don't
i have no relationship with caffeine
at all
okay i'll have a hot chocolate once a
week just because i like chocolate not
because i'm after the caffeine that's in
it so and i can sleep like that i i can
walk away from this camera lay down on
the ground on the carpet here and be
asleep 10 minutes later so i've never
been angrier at a person in my life
like you're just basically saying
everything that's haunted you your whole
life doesn't really affect me but it
must be hard
so what i'm saying is i tried a
meditation app you know where it said
sit down
focus on your breath did a lot of the
stuff you were describing and i just
went to sleep i because
you know
a soft voice talks begins to talk to you
and
and i'm sorry i just go to sleep and so
maybe i'm i'm i'm meditation proof okay
because i can't
am i unreachable by meditation because i
don't
i don't believe anybody is let me ask
you this let me reframe it because i
love everything you just said and i i
want your mind
um on many levels where in your life do
you struggle
so i don't think about it that way i
think about it like okay i'm struggling
because i'm academic right and so i
spent my whole life there's a book in
front of me and i don't know what's in
it i gotta study it and so then i work
through it you slog through it you the
brush and bramble you get a little
bloody maybe you know if it's a
particularly difficult physics problem
or something and then you get through it
on the other side and the the the reward
is that much sweeter for having
struggled to get there so for me a
struggle is not something to bring
to bring angst within me
it i'm attracted to it i say well i
don't understand that let me keep at it
and that that excites me
and so i don't i so i don't i can't
think about it the way you ask me the
question about it
well
if we
talk to everybody in your life
off the record
uh
would they say there are
days where you have a bad day or
relationships that are fraught um
or is there a struggle in your life i
can never be woke enough for my daughter
my 25 year old daughter
my dad fight constantly that's what i'm
saying as woke as i think i am i that i
will never be woken up so i i
you know we talk and
um there's tension if i'm if i dig my
heels in based on my own life experience
but she's a life experience that's that
that has vectors going forward
not looking backwards and so i'm
intrigued by that challenged by it and
intrigued by it but for me every
challenge is an academic challenge now
with regard to relationships there's
other complexities there right a married
33 years and the you know the big secret
of marriage is that marriage is work all
right because it fairy tales you know
where where do all the fairy tales end
they end
at the marriage
right so it's advice for the courtship
but they don't tell you what to do after
you get married they just they lived
happily ever really
really you know give me give me some
stories on the other side of that of
that trench all right so
so
um
so i don't know i think
sure you know talk you can talk to my
relatives and they'll say well he does
this and he does that and he does that
but
you're telling me that meditation is
much more for yourself and what you need
and what you want and so so that's an
interesting
uh wait can i have a pitch can i say a
pitch go for it to me it sounds like you
said you tackle everything like an
academic challenge but what the
challenge of meditation is correct me if
i'm wrong it's like you have to see your
own brain as something that's worthy of
study and something that's worthy of
growth and understanding and so you're
like i don't have the typical struggles
of somebody else but meditation might be
helpful
for you to understand how your own mind
works even more
all right dan if that's if if marsha's
correct she is so okay
okay so
what is for you i mean everybody's got
to have their way in i think she
astutely obser identified one way in for
a for a mind like yours that is really
interested in science really interested
in the details figuring things out
buddhism
and meditation i think would have an
enormous amount to offer you because the
mind
is massively complex and fascinating and
in many ways lawful and you can get
interested in what makes it work
so that's for example you're suggesting
because that's not how you began you
began by saying i had this problem that
that met problem and meditation solved
it and if you have problems in your life
medication
medicaid meditation
medication works too
meditation
can help you overcome them um
master them and the like if you have no
such litany of problems and you're not
on any kind of prescription drugs you're
now saying
that i'm not challenging you i'm just
asking you you're now saying that the
meditation can
enhance
whatever it is you're doing well and
maybe even do it better is that i've
shown that yeah i think many things are
true simultaneously just as when we talk
about astrophysics where i know nothing
but you can talk about one way in with
meditation which is i think the most
common way in which is suffering people
yeah most of us suffer neil from anxiety
yes but for you
[Laughter]
for you i think that there's a
there's a
i i think it's phenomenal the the the
there's an enormous amount of wisdom i
hear coming through in your description
of your own mind state and that's
amazing i don't think you have to
meditate i'm not a meditation
fundamentalist i think for you the
evangelical evangelical fundamentalist
meditator
the trick the interesting door for you
might be just intellectual interest
because there's so the mind is so vast
and is so interesting and i think there
would be a lot there for you to play
with it i just want to respond to one
last thing which is you said meditation
is all about your own mind but what we
know what we know about the universe is
that the line between self and other is
porous and blurry
and you can't if you look close your
eyes and look for the self for some
little homunculus of marsha or neil or
dan in the mind you cannot find it we
can't find the seat of consciousness in
the brain and so
we are
interdependent with other people and
with the universe at large and so
meditation the modern world for that in
physics would be we are entangled
yes yes yes
because of entanglement
working on your own mind is
working for the greater good the same
you you you can do both at the same time
connect with others so you connect with
yourself
i have no rebuttal to that perspective
very good
uh
so dan i think we have to land this
plane um where can we find your your app
and and uh what do you what is your
greatest presence on social media i i
have i'm on twitter i'm not super active
um
i post mostly pictures of my child or
our cats
my podcast is the place where i'm most
active which you can find wherever you
get your podcasts it's called 10 happier
i also have a meditation app my team and
i we we've got a large team of people
we're building this meditation app which
you can get wherever you get your apps
excellent so it's easy to find because
i'll name the same thing and i assume
you're are you dan harris on twitter
i think it's dan b harris dan b harris
okay
b is for for beefcake since i'm
did meditation get you to think that way
i'm still working on it one of my many
challenges is is self-centeredness so
i'm still trying to shave that down all
right well dan's been delight to have
you and just congratulations on trying
to having improved yourself and now
attempting to improve others because at
the end of the day the world is better
off
for people like you having lived in it
so
imagine new york if we weren't all just
walking around having panic attacks all
the time
it would be a different world
[Laughter]
excellent okay it's great to meet you
and thank i'm a long time fan so great
to meet you neil and marcia i'm a new
fan and great to meet you as well thank
you you too so nice to meet you so we
when we come back we're going to bring
on
star talk
a correspondent can i call can i use
that word starts star talk brain
correspondent heather berlin when star
talk returns
we're back star talk we're talking about
meditation coming off our first segment
in a conversation with dan harris abc
correspondent turned meditation guru ooh
do i get to use that word marshall i
think so yeah yeah totally we can
totally do that and as is the dna of
star talk we bring in an academic expert
on a subject matter that any of our um
pop culture
representatives bring to the table and
of course we have our
neuroscientist at large heather berlin
welcome back heather
always a pleasure always
yeah and you're you're at the icon
school of medicine did i say that right
yes the icon school of medicine at mount
sinai
h and at mount sinai
and
you specialize in
figuring out what the brain is doing
whether or not people know it i think
that's on your business card isn't it
yes yes exactly
so let's make sure again bring up some
broad
questions here that
arose from that first segment so many
people who have
mental
challenges
right one of them a big one i i'm told
is is anxiety but
no no but there are others there's
trauma in life for example possibly even
ptsd
you can think of things that a problem
that a person can't shake
shake away from themselves and
um
you know as a
clinical person is your first thought
yeah there's a drug for that
or at what point does someone say
there's a drug for that
and at what point does someone say
get to know your mind better maybe you
can have mind over matter
mind over
a properly behaving mind over the mind
that's misfiring so how does how do you
strike a balance between those two
yeah i mean often you know we start with
the kinds of treatments that are
non-medication-based treatments um you
do and then yeah
yeah for sure and that would be i mean
you know forms various forms of talk
therapy using techniques yeah you know
mindfulness based stress reduction or or
meditation as part it's integrated as
part of therapy um you know
because
your thoughts
you know can change your brain
and that is a way to change your
neurochemistry just via controlling your
thoughts and and your emotions and how
you respond to them so um
we always we always do that first now if
people's
neurochemical imbalance or nerve
circuitry is in such a way that that is
not enough then we can supplement or
augment that with medication and then we
find that there's a synergistic effect
so that the medication plus the
mindfulness base or the talk therapies
um work together better than either one
of them alone so it's never just like
here's a pill now go off and and you
know you'll be better it's it's always
going to be a bit of both but but we
start always with
non-medical treatments and then sort of
move up the ladder but wait isn't a pill
cheaper than therapy
i'm just thinking
it's bad it's cheaper and faster than
therapy
yeah
yeah if you know the neurochemistry
the electrochemistry of let's just
whoever defines it i don't care it
doesn't matter of a normal brain okay
this is a brain that doesn't have
uh neurological issues that we have
identified in textbooks
is that the chemistry you're going to
try to recreate in the mind of someone
who has mental challenges
so
first of all there's no such thing
really as a normal brain every brain is
different and now when we're talking
about people at the extremes
yes you know people with extreme um
neurochemical imbalances or um problems
in their neuroanatomy but outside of
those extremes everybody is has
something basically everybody we're all
wired differently and so there's no one
ideal place that we're trying to get a
person to be at so that's why psychiatry
is is an art more so even than a science
you know it's not like we know okay it's
not like you have this bacteria take
this antibiotic you know it is
try this ssri or a selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor and see if that has
an effect and then we sort of measure
how is it affecting that person and if
it works great if not okay we'll try
this struggle we'll try that so there's
no perfect there's also dosing too right
the dosage
yeah there's no there's no ideal state
we're trying to get it just it's really
individualized medicine what works for
you based on your symptomology you know
what kind of treatment do we think is
gonna be best for you and so there's no
ideal state it's just it's just what's
good for you
so if you're a person who's an
overthinker you have a highly active
prefrontal cortex and you're ruminating
and you can't stop that inner voice you
know giving you techniques to how to
quiet it down how to focus your
attention is one way if that doesn't
help you need something stronger then we
can help bring in certain drugs and see
if that has an effect or not you know
there's just no perfect drugs are those
over thinker types
that sounds horrible
so heather let me ask you uh
an awkward philosophical question
all right and i i i come to you from the
world of physics and in physics
uh we we physics has been around a long
time what i mean by that is there are
things we've actually understood about
the universe over many many centuries
by the works the hard work and
brilliance of key people who have been
in our field that is a much deeper
history
than
psychiatry or psychology right when you
think of sort of modern psych psychology
it's is it much more than a century old
really i mean maybe late 1800s with
physics we have authentic physics going
back
500 years okay
so my my question is could it be
that
neuroscience or or or a couch
uh you know
couch therapy
is something that needs
breakthroughs of brilliant
neuro people who haven't been born yet
so that the day will come will you say
you'll just analyze the neural chemistry
and say here's what's wrong fix it here
nip tuck do the truck boom and you walk
out the door and it's one session in
your house okay ready this i love this
question so first of all i mean
psychology i need buy-in on this marcia
are you with me on this was this i'm
freaked out because to me it's like
because it's about the human brain it
can never be standardized in the way
that physics is because humans are
consciousness just like we were talking
about in the first segment it's about
our consciousness i don't buy that never
told you
i'm gonna be devil's advocacy scan my
brain i'd be terrified they'd use it for
evil
so no here's what okay there was a day
we look up at the night sky oh the moon
is doing this and that and that's
different from what mercury is doing and
that's different for and everybody's
doing their thing in the sky
yeah and no one really understands it
and so we're thinking oh my gosh well
we'll never understand it because we are
mortal and that's the divine space of
the heavens and how can we ever
understand divine thinking i see what
you're saying now yeah and then single
formulas come forth and it brings it all
together under one coherent
understanding
so are we in this moment
declaring the brain is just complex and
we can never do it or are you admitting
ignorance about where we
relative to where we could be one day
so that the person walks in you put him
in one of your machines that i know you
got in the back room there in your home
and then goes boop and then everything
is fixed like i said one-stop shop yeah
like please
okay
oh i'll tackle this in two minutes or
less um psychology arose out of
philosophy philosophy was the origins of
psychology but technically if you really
you know the the science of the mind you
know maybe a century a century and a
half old true
the the problem with the brain
is subjectivity so i've always been
interested in the brain because i want
to understand the neural basis of
consciousness how does this physical
piece of matter create subjective states
the most subjective thing there is in
the world exactly so if i ask you are
you depressed you know i can look at how
you're acting whatever but i have to ask
you on a scale of one to ten how sad do
you feel or how much pain are you in
right so until we can solve that problem
of subjectivity which is really what we
want to work towards is having a unified
theory of the neural basis of
consciousness and and we're working on
that right now we do not have that we do
not have an agreed upon theory of
consciousness and marcia you know the
best evidence that they don't have it
is that if you go to the bookstore and
you look for books on consciousness
they're shelf after shelf
and not just one not just one book
just one book on gravity on the shelf
and there's 50 books on consciousness
that means we know nothing about
consciousness whoever can figure this
out but we're narrowing it down
if you figure it out though don't tell
anybody because i don't want the clones
i don't want the
i don't want it
well this is the thing the thing about
consciousness is it's first person
subjective experience so the only one
that can ever experience your
consciousness is you to know what it
feels like to be you but there are a
couple of main contenders of like one is
this integrated information theory of
consciousness the other is the global
neuronal workspace theory of
consciousness some talk about predictive
processing and coding so there's a bunch
of theories out there floating around
and we're actually engaged in a large
scale study right now across labs
to
test these different theories against
each other experimentally which is very
difficult to do in and of itself because
of the problem of subject subjectivity
also could the concept of consciousness
itself
be
malformed in how you even pose the
question
well yeah so i once actually debated
deepak chopra on this topic because he
is he's philosophizing that
consciousness just exists in the
universe it's a fundamental property of
the universe and we are just subjects of
that we it creates matter right where i
say no matter or me and my fellow
neuroscientists matter creates
subjectivity creates consciousness but
there are some
people with different philosophical
views that say it exists in the universe
and we're just like the conduits of it
this is further evidence that nobody
really knows anything
the universe gives it to you and the
other person says that you give it to
the universe right if that's what you're
arguing about
you don't know anything we're far from
but i do ultimately think that in the if
we don't kill ourselves first as a human
species and over the course of time
you know theories will emerge and and we
will get closer um but because each
brain is slightly different you would
have to take each individual map out
their entire brain understand their full
history um and also the brain isn't
static it's constantly changing so where
you were yesterday is different than
where you are today so it's a moving
target
so with so many variables involved that
it's really hard yeah to pinpoint um and
to change it in a way that's going to
suit your it's going to change the
person's behavior however the one thing
we are getting closer with our neural
implants where we can you know make a
rat move left or right depending on how
we direct it or make it eat or not eat
and so we can start to control human
behavior but
if we can control how you feel and think
you know i mean we'll eventually get
there i'm sure you know
yeah just yeah that's a little scary i'm
scared of that marshall she said when
neural implants to control your behavior
yes okay now every time i go left or
right i'm gonna go am i doing good
someone else making me
heather i want to hear from you
about the the
clinical studies and laboratory studies
of what the brain is doing when it's
meditating or when it's not meditating
or or just what what what going inside
the brain tells us about what's going on
outside when star talk returns
we're back star talk segment three of
meditation
and
we began with dan harris who set us on
this path uh he's got a meditation app
called ten percent smarter is it marcia
ten percent happier happier ten percent
happier i think yeah no we
we really want one that makes us all ten
percent smarter all right that we gotta
work on that one and we brought in
heather berlin our neuroscientist at
large to help make sense of all of this
neurological sense um heather uh all
this talk about changes in people's
behavior for whatever reason be it
meditation or drugs do you see that in
brain scans or
neural implants or whatever it is you do
behind a curtain when nobody's looking
do we see changes in the brain after
meditation yeah and amazingly so so all
these studies have been done you know
they have people who never meditate it
before and then they have them meditate
for eight weeks and then look at their
brains you know before and after
and they also look at long-term
meditators you know people have been
practicing their whole life
and you actually see an increase in gray
matter so normally the brain is aging
right over time and we're having a sort
of a little bit of atrophy of gray
matter and they found that meditators
long-term meditators a 50 year old brain
looks like what a 25 year old brain
would look like remind me what gray
matter does for us gray matter is
involved in all of our thinking our
cognition um planning organizing it's
particularly in the prefrontal cortex
they see these changes so what's the
point of the decision making you just
listen to everything i want my brain for
so what good is
sensory it's all your sensory
information the subcortical areas are
more of the emotional parts of your
brain your drives your motivation but
they actually see changes in those areas
too so they have um the amygdala
involved in a fear response your kind of
fight-or-flight response actually were
smaller and in the short-term meditators
the people who just did it for eight
weeks they looked at their amygdala
activation in response to emotional
pictures before meditating and then
after and they had less amygdala
activation to pictures after they had
meditated so they had more emotional
control so increases in prefrontal
cortex gray matter means that they can
you can regulate yourself you can have
more impulse control control over
emotions um and it actually you see
these decreases in these subcortical
areas so it's both you get these these
activation changes and you get really
structural changes in the brain with
meditation over time okay so you have
value judged
in what you just said you value judged
those changes but yes well but the
amygdala is a huge part of anxiety right
because that's basically like your fight
or flight is triggered but there's
nothing to run from so like your
outside's not matching your inside and
i've heard that meditation yeah like
that's interesting because i've heard
that meditation just helps calm that
fight or flight oh interesting marcia so
you're saying that sometimes we're
reacting
in a way that would have been sensible
if t-rex were chasing us exactly except
except that
that's not the threat
you see that a lot i had a job where i
worked with holocaust survivors and
their kids had
even worse anxiety than them because
they grow up with all this physical
anxiety but their experience outwardly
is very safe so it doesn't make sense
and then they've now done studies about
that that kids of trauma and things like
the holocaust
have these experiences with their brain
chemistry and it's just interesting
hearing the science behind it because
i've heard about the amygdala and stuff
right but heather all right so i'll give
you that but how about any activity that
someone does intensely for eight weeks
if i if i take up chess and i get really
into chess or some
or some uh i don't know martial arts
does that change the brain yeah
something that takes a lot of focus and
intensity so is is is meditation unique
in this regard or is it just anything
you do
with focus and intensity will also
trigger or
instill change permanent changes in the
brain absolutely but it's this it's the
skill set that you're training because
your brain habituates it learns anything
so if you're doing something bad like
things that are related to addiction you
get into a negative negative changes in
the brain but in this case what you're
learning with meditation is you're
increasing activation in parts of the
brain that have to do with
um
your sort of what they call it quieting
your your sort of monkey mind that inner
chatter that self-critic
the you know the kind of inner voice
that's the inner critic that's telling
you you're not doing well or all the
negative thinking and you're gaining
more control over those negative
thoughts you're getting more control
over i mean emotions are good to have
but not when they're being triggered for
the wrong reasons right so what happens
you have a fast track to a motion where
the amygdala gets activated but then the
pre the prefrontal cortex says oh wait
you know this there's nothing dangerous
in this situation you can calm down now
but if you don't have the right
regulation to do that
you're a victim of your own
neurochemistry exactly but this way
you're taking control in a way over your
your brain it's like the brain
controlling itself so with meditation
you're becoming more aware of what's
happening internally in your own mind
and you're gaining more control so that
you can enhance your positive
experiences and help down regulate the
negative ones and the thoughts you know
what i did once heather uh i was 17
and there was
uh a
friend of our family a friend of my
mother's who had a son who was also 17
but i nev
we played together when we were like
three but i didn't know him
and he died of brain cancer it was very
tragic and
there was a funeral in
rivers the chapel at riverside church
and they it was during a school day and
he he went to school in westchester but
they took a bus of kids brought them
into manhattan and that and there's a
picture of him on the casket and and the
organ is doing its organ thing funeral
organ thing
everybody's crying
everybody's crying and i'm saying to
myself
i
i swear this is my this is my this is
what i said to myself i said
i do not know this person
yet every force operating in the air
right now
wants me to cry over his death
the the you know
15 16 year old kids helping each other
walk down the aisle and he's a handsome
kid so there's this handsome photo of
him and i said
and tears started welling up in my eyes
and i said
i'm only crying
because everybody else is crying i don't
actually feel this
at all i said this to myself and then i
said
why don't i cry every day
because thousands of people die every
day in new york city for all kinds of
reasons
i'm not crying then
so why should i cry now
suck those tears back up and i i still
felt the moment
but i did not let the moment override
emotions that i felt were artificially
implanted in me i did that when i was
17. i don't know if i should be proud of
that moment
or i cry at state farm commercials
i cry at the commercial where the woman
sings with the the dogs you know oh the
most manipulative bring grandma in and
you haven't seen her in 20 years i'll be
sobbing all of these they're trying to
manipulate me and so heather i if are
you saying that i did something good or
did i do something
um uh
you know yeah so this is
there's two there's it's interesting so
there's
what we put a value judgment you know
one of which is if you can have the
right kinds of emotional control you
know be able to express your emotions at
the appropriate time but not express
them when you're being manipulated to do
so and whatnot so in that sense yes i
can tell you that organ was all in on
[Laughter]
you're supposed to cry at a funeral
because there's a collective release
with ritual even if like it's not it's
like i feel like our culture is so shied
away from death that that's why you're
that's why you're supposed to cry but i
also went to some funerals where some
people i'm like you're doing this for
attention which is wrong yeah okay
so i think the emotional control can be
a good thing um over again over
controlled like you know if you if you
didn't cry if it was the funeral of
someone you did know and had a
connection to you that'd be a little
different but the other aspect is um and
what meditation also helps increase the
brain areas involved in is empathy so
you can have an empathetic response you
can like the boundary between self and
other it can dissolve and you can feel
more connected with people um so you can
increase empathy but at the same time
have enough cognitive control
to um control your emotions in the
appropriate way
so i so i drew my line between tears
dropping down my cheek i said i felt it
it was a very sad day and so it's not
that i didn't feel the sadness
but
i i just could not and and you know i've
been to some new orleans funerals right
where there is a jazz band and there's
there's a celebration so i don't think
it's rich in the sky that one must cry
at a funeral
you can use that time to celebrate the
person's life however brief they were on
earth but you know what you were
exhibiting which is really at that young
age was this sort of meta awareness you
know you were making a decision about
how you were going to choose to i was i
was a geek kid i was a complete geek kid
so there was this whole like parts of
the brain modulating other parts of the
brain and that's what meditators do i
once did this um experiment with this
shaolin monk who could it withstand an
enormous amount of pain and so we put
him in the scanner and we put these
these heaters on his wrists and we would
just keep increasing the heat heat to
the point that he had burn marks on it
and he was just saying i feel the pain i
feel the pain i mean look at his brain
marshall this is this is the stuff
heather does
this was in the uk this was in the uk
totally different roles there different
different legislative
when he was controlling this pain
you saw one part of his brain
controlling the pain network in the
brain so he was literally using one part
of his brain this executive control to
down regulate the pain network because
pain doesn't happen in your arm it
happens in your brain so if you can
control one part of your brain with the
other you cannot experience pain there
are people who go through surgery
without anesthesia by going to a
meditative state so it's just amazing
how much we're talking about this meta
awareness how much control we can really
have beyond what we even think is
physiologically possible we can control
our own physiology i i hate to confess
then i used to do that i well i used to
wrestle and wrestle there's a lot of
things that are painful when you're
wrestling and i would say to myself well
is is the skin broken and am i bleeding
no
therefore ignore it and keep going
they've shown athletes that's like there
was a really fascinating like sports
science thing where about how athletes
can play through a broken leg just by
pure
pain control and adrenaline and like the
chemicals that come up where you can
have a super bad injury and finish the
game and then not feel the pain until
afterwards essentially but then
sometimes the pain is excruciating once
they finally do
feel it but they'll say i played for two
hours on a broken leg didn't feel a
thing as soon as the game was over
i you know collapsed yeah so but in my
case i would make the judgment whether
it was just
pain that pain sensors were sending to
my brain or whether there's an actual
physiological
break that needed attention right the
medical attention i'd make that
distinction and if it was just simply
pain no matter how severe
i would just ignore it and keep going
and and i and
so i hope heather that that doesn't mean
i can't feel for people right is that
what you're telling me that i think
there are two different systems that are
going on one is this capacity to feel
empathy right which is a whole neural
network in and of itself which you you
can very well have i don't know i may
have to run some tests on you but you
know
i'll give you the benefit of the doubt
for now so that's one thing so it
doesn't necessarily correlate with how
much cognitive control or you know
control you have over your thoughts and
over pain so you can have a ton of
cognitive or control or emotional
regulation and that doesn't necessarily
relate to how empathetic or not you are
you know when you they the reason they
get they get construct they get sort of
pushed together is because psychopaths
tend to have an enormous amount of
control and also don't have empathy but
but in
in you know non-psychopathic humans um
they don't have to be correlated so
heather just a quick question before we
uh close out the segment do you meditate
at all are you so in touch with your
neuroscience that that's beneath you
right of course yes i was born in a very
no i i um i do meditate but she's got a
i bet she's got a meditation machine in
the back
the implants i just turn on meditation
meditation mode
the thing about meditation is that
there's this false narrative that you
have to be like sitting perfectly you
know in this sort of like legs crossed
position or whatever it is and be saying
um
and you know you can really meditate
anywhere anytime anyplace and the the
more you can incorporate into your daily
life you know you're waiting online you
know to get your cup of coffee and you
could go and you can kind of become
focused inward you know go into your
default mode be very present in the
moment be very mindful of what's
happening around you and so so i try to
incorporate meditation into my daily
practice every day wherever i am and i
have a moment but other things i do is i
go for walks in the woods and i say this
is my time i'm going to meditate but my
meditation can be just looking at the
trees and you know being fully aware of
what's going on around me or doing yoga
um so it's not like i wake up in the
morning like okay this is my 20 minutes
of meditation i'm going to turn on my
app not that you know apps are great but
but everybody has their own way to
incorporate into their life and i say
the more flexible it is and the more you
can find time to just be present
and and look in and check in with
yourself um the better guys we got to
land this plane but this has been uh
highly enlightening and
and introspective uh uncommon for what
we normally do for star talk so i'm glad
to have you contribute to this heather
and
this has been a star talk an episode on
meditation and and mindfulness
and maybe we'll revisit this because it
seems to be an endless topic uh surely
um right for future
advances and discoveries that heather
will be our
neuroscientist at large to bring i'll be
your neuroscientist guru guru all right
guys this has been star talk i'm your
host neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you